one of the main item on the agenda of
today's council was enlargement and
stabilisation and association process we
have adopted the presidency statement
that covered turkey Montenegro Serbia
the former yugoslav republic of
macedonia albania bosnia herzegovina and
kosovo and let me say quite frankly that
we wanted to achieve more we wanted to
have counsel conclusions however one
country was unable to support the
compromise which all remaining 27 member
states found acceptable when put on the
table we welcome the new approach to
address the fundamental reforms early in
the process especially when it comes to
the rule of law and fundamental rights
it's clear to understand that the
enlargement process is not about giving
gifts to the participating countries but
it's really about hard and credible work
that benefits both sides the council
formally adopted its negotiating
position on the european fund for
sustainable development and this is an
important milestone in our efforts to
make this fund a reality this fund is a
vital instrument which aims in
particular at tackling the root causes
of irregular migration by creating job
opportunities encouraging investments
and facilitating sustainable
developments in partner countries in
africa as well as in the european
union's neighborhood we have approved
the joint declaration setting out the
eels priorities for the year 2017 as
agreed by the silver presidency with the
European Commission and the European
Parliament this is the first time that
the three EU institutions agree on a
legislative priorities for the following
year